you have your acoustic guitar they do  what would you do another one for us so  it left just you in the guitar have you  ever seen the rain about the band  breaking up  someone told me long ago there's a calm  reaper storm  hello  it's been coming for some time when it's  over so when they say it'll rain a sunny  day I know  shining down water  have you ever seen the rain I wanna know  where have you ever seen  I'm in down a sunny day yesterday and  days before Sun is cold or raining hard  I know we've been that way for how my  time you'll forever haunt it goes  through the circle fast and slow I know  it can't stop I wonder I wanna know  have you ever seen a rain  I wanna know we'll have you ever seen  coming down a Sun a day  boy that's some song even if you just  written that song and no other songs  would have been enough but you're such a  show-off  you have hey yes I am actually yes